if someone sent you a link to this video
it's probably a good idea to pay
attention to the things on this list
let's go
hey what's up guys mkbhd here now i
recently created a community on google
plus where it was just for youtubers by
youtubers anyone could join the
community if they're a youtuber and
surprisingly it's one of the top 15
communities on all of google plus right
now over 10 000 people have joined it
already now it's not like i didn't
already know youtube was big but i was
surprised that so many people joined it
so fast so it kind of reminded me how
many youtubers there are so without any
further ado this is a little quick list
for just good gifts to give a youtuber
this holiday season first thing on this
list is a high capacity and high speed
sd card if your youtuber friend has an 8
gig sd card get him a 16 gig if he has a
16 gig get him a 32 gig if he has a 32
gig get him a faster 32 gig or a 64 gig
i am using a 64 gig class 10 sd card and
if you can get your person a class 10 sd
card that's about the fastest you can
get and it's going to make a world of
difference for shooting video and
definitely worth it for the transfer
speeds second is a gorillapod and this
was actually one of my first more
creative types of things that i use to
make videos a gorillapod is something
you can use to get all sorts of crazy
angles and weird types of latching onto
things to get shots hanging off a tree
branch hanging off a banister whatever
you want to do but it's going to allow
your youtuber to get more creative shots
and just experiment with being more
creative with video and i think that's
ultimately what youtube's all about so
gorillapod you could get your youtuber
friend a youtube shirt i don't actually
own one yet so if someone i know is
watching this video and wants to get me
a gift a youtube shirt that'll be pretty
sweet a new mouse because people who
edit video a lot tend to use their mouse
more than anything and if you can get a
mouse that they already know that they
like that would be great but you know
the cyborg rat 7 the logitech revolution
there's a whole bunch of great mice out
there for video editing or just for
general everyday use for people who use
the computer a lot so these are all
things you can probably get for less
than 100 bucks and then there's the
nexus 7. i add this to the list because
not only is it a great tablet for
youtube video watching but if you do
some little hackery or just install some
software and grab a cable you can
actually make this a video monitor for
your canon dslr so if you happen to have
someone on your list who has a canon
dslr and wants a nexus 7 they can
actually use it as a video monitor and
control their dslr from their tablet so
is it a great tablet yes but it's an
even better video monitor a reflector
because not all of us have studio lights
a 50 millimeter lens if you know someone
who shoots with a dslr they're probably
going to want sort of a prime lens
that's sort of that optimal focal length
where you can get wide angle shots and
close-up shots and a 50 mm lens is great
typically the nifty 50 that's really
really cheap for both canon and nikon is
a 50 millimeter f 1.8 lens it is a very
inexpensive and very sharp lens allows
you to get a blurry background nice
depth of field and it's really great
value it was my first video lens and
that's where i first really started
getting created with dslr videos so 50
mm lens is really high up there on the
list and if all else fails a gift card a
gift card to something like amazon or a
b h or a store you know that sells that
sort of equipment video equipment where
they can pick up a microphone or
contribute it to a new lens i personally
prefer amazon gift cards they're super
easy again all the links for the stuff
that i'm recommending will be right
below the like button on this video in
the description and that's pretty much
the most effective thing you can get a
person as a gift card that they can
spend on whatever they want but of
course if all else fails you can just
ask them what they want
either way thanks for watching this
video just a quick video of some things
i just thought of real quick that would
be nice to get a youtuber wink wink for
a holiday and uh if you want maybe some
other themed version of this leave a
thumbs up or i don't know what i could
do like a best gifts under 200 or best
gifts for
geek i don't know leave a comment below
if you have an idea for that and i'll
probably work on that if you want me to
do it but either way that's been it
thanks for watching this quick mkbhd
video and more coming up soon thanks
peace
so
you